hi I'm a Mac and I'm a PC surprised you
showed up alone no security guard to
protect you from the angry mob of
Windows 8 users don't need them anymore
Windows 10 comes out today
did I miss 9 or is that in the grave
already with Clippy and the Zune good
one but you won't be laughing soon
Windows 10 actually does a lot of stuff
better than a Mac and in some places
feels more modern can you say the same
thing when Vista was released and I
think Windows ME I'll prove it to you
lots of people are happy that the start
button is back but the real game changer
are the new tricks to manage multiple
windows you can get this improved view
when you swipe three fingers up on the
trackpad click this task View button or
hit the Windows and tab keys so you took
expose and gave it a different name
revolutionary yeah well where did you
get the idea of split screen apps that's
coming up in your iOS 9 and Mac OS L
copy time whatever yeah what we're doing
it better than you anyway
you can still drag windows to the edges
to snap them side by side far easier
than holding down a button Mac the
system suggests app pairings and on a
bigger screen you can even arrange for
apps my favorite trick is maneuvering
them around by just holding down the
windows key and tapping the arrows wow
that keyboard shortcut looks great
actually would really speed things up
for me and wait till you see how helpful
Cortana is on the desktop what's the
weather in Hong Kong
it's currently 82 and raining but she's
really speedy at searching and launching
apps and websites and because she can
access your calendar and email she
reminds you of things and feeds you the
news you want it's one of many things
that makes even upgrading from Windows
seven worth it
Siri why don't you come to the Mac but
what about apps that's what an operating
systems really about are you're still
old and ugly and what about PC virus
software that's still popping up all
over the place
sorry did you say something I'm updating
right now our core apps like photos are
okay but aren't as good as Apple or
Google's and we've got all the
traditional software but finding a good
third-party app for Twitter or photo
editing isn't easy you spend most of
your time in the browser though so we
have this new edge browser it's fast and
has some cool features but honestly even
I still use Chrome Oh does it work with
my iPhone and our Windows PC is still
pretty crappy yes it works with your
iPhone all of Microsoft's big services
are available for the iPhone or are
coming soon if you want to do Mac things
like it iMessage on your computer you're
at a look and you're right
Apple still makes better quality
hardware and trackpads than most Windows
PCs but you know what you can actually
try Windows 10 on your Mac and it works
really well I will try that
nice job PC now just try not to mess
with things for a while maybe I won't
make fun of you as much oh by the way
your fly's unzipped